vou começar com uma pergunta a gente
está falando em criatividade aqui não
vou ser muito criativo você é muito
original né então a pergunta na verdade
é do professor shipping quer um toque
que a gente teve esse ano
aconselho vocês assistirem que lhe
perguntou o mundo está melhor
essa pergunta é né ele comprovou com os
gráficos maravilhosos que o mundo sim a
melhor na maioria dos indicadores que a
gente buscar questões econômicas
questões ambientais questões sociais
tá eu trago essa pergunta inovando um
pouquinho perguntando se o brasil está
melhor
o brasil é melhor né comparado ao que
comparado a quando se a gente for pegar
algumas décadas
a gente vê que sim o brasil está melhor
na maior parte dos indicadores que a
gente olhar tá então trago aqui alguns
números com relação ao por exemplo
mortalidade infantil e mortalidade
infantil na década de 80 de 1980 estava
próximo a 90 da potabilidade infantil
até um ano em mil nascidos né
e hoje esse número tem aproximadamente
14 em tão maravilhoso é maravilhoso
quando a gente vai para a questão por
exemplo de desmatamento
o desmatamento desde 2004 ele veio
caindo o que é um dado também muito
positivo muito interessante para a gente
quando a gente olha a questão de
mulheres no mercado de trabalho
esse é um outro dado super interessante
vem melhorando cada dia mais com a
participação de negros e negras mercado
de trabalho vem melhorando a cada dia
mais
mas tá bom tá bom
essa pergunta eu acho que não né porque
enquanto porque enquanto a gente tiver
uma criança morrendo quando tiver uma
árvore sendo desmatada de maneira
irregular
quando a gente não tiver uma sociedade
justa igual a gente tem que perseguir
para alcançar esses números que eu falei
pra vocês eles têm alguns recortes né
então desmatamento ele vem aumentando
os anos a mortalidade infantil que eu
disse
ela aumentou no último ano então a gente
vem sim melhorando muito está muito
melhor do que há décadas atrás mas como
disse
a gente está piorando nos últimos anos
além disso tem algumas questões bastante
fundamentais e muito importantes como
acabamos de ver a palestra danone klein
que é mudança do clima
crises e migratórias então esses pontos
são muito importantes e estão mudando o
mundo assim como o brasil
foi dito ainda pouco como a mudança do
clima já é percebida no brasil e quanto
ela já vem afetando nossas cidades
quanto já vem afetando nossos municípios
quanto vem nos afetando no dia a dia
isso já é uma realidade então por isso
eu queria lembrar que a gente nunca pode
se apegar algumas coisas com relação á
dado histórico é importante é importante
ver que estamos melhorando temos que
comemorar mas temos que olhar como
estamos hoje
além disso a questão de médias médias
elas nos trazem uma falsa sensação seja
de segurança uma falta percepção da
realidade
tá então como eu comentei a questão de
mortalidade infantil a média no brasil
hoje é de 14
tá mas se a gente for olhar para estados
como norte nordeste
esse número é muito maior
se olharmos a questão de acesso à água
25 milhões de pessoas no brasil só no
brasil não têm acesso à água de
qualidade
metade da nossa população metade da
nossa população
esse ano eu acho bem bizarro né não têm
acesso a saneamento básico
então recupera-se informação a gente não
pode se perder em médias e a gente tem
que localizar as agendas localizar
significa e para onde ela é de fato
necessária
por isso as nações unidas em 2015
adotaram o que vocês estão vendo aqui os
o ds que vencemos o défice objetivo o
desenvolvimento sustentável
quando a gente fala dessa a gente tem
que olhar na verdade da agenda 2030
agenda 2030 é a agenda de
desenvolvimento sustentável e sempre
corrijam quando vocês escutarem ea
agenda de desenvolvimento sustentável da
onu não é da onu
tá né da onu é de todos nós
ela foi feito ela foi feita e ela foi
adotada no âmbito na instância das
nações unidas mas na verdade com uma
consulta bastante ampla envolvendo
sociedade civil envolvendo o setor
privado envolvendo governos locais
subnacionais então cidades estados e
claro envolvendo países
então no dia 25 de setembro ela foi ali
adotada
o que é interessante é que da agenda que
a gente tem que notar essa agenda em
algumas premissas
uma delas é que ela é interligada
integrada indivisível que significa isso
conta a história que é muito boa mas
acho que vale a pena a gente contar para
a gente entender esses três disso da
agenda não é bastante chocante que é o
que ainda no mundo milhões de pessoas
algumas centenas de milhões andam mais
de cinco quilômetros por dia para
buscarem água quando a gente anda alguns
passos para ter água potável a água
limpa
as pessoas andam e muitas vezes não é
uma água de qualidade
então quando eu falo isso só nessa frase
eu tratei de alguns o ds que estão ali
então o trato de ads um que fala de
pobreza eu trato jds 6 fala de água
dos sete que fala de energia e
continuando a história fala do 10
desigualdades por que não e continuando
a história
o que a gente tem quantos vocês acham
dessas pessoas que vão buscar água
energia madeira quanto vocês acham que
são mulheres
quando vocês estariam escutei 50 70%
aqui na verdade é 90% noventa por cento
65 por cento mulheres e 25% meninas
tá então aqui eu falo do que o ds5
eu venho pra mais uma parte da história
a maior parte dos estupros que ocorre no
mundo ocorrem no trajeto em busca de
água e energia
então aqui eu trago 10 e 16 de justiça
de violência então por isso gente a
gente tem sempre lembrar que as agenda
ela é interligada indivisível integrada
não dá pra gente olhar sobre um aspecto
a gente tem que olhar o todo e eu
pergunto a vocês
de quem é a responsabilidade da agenda
de quem é quem tem que fazer essa agenda
andar nessa agenda como diria uma grande
amiga o tio do lixo da humanidade ou
seja lista de afazeres da humanidade né
como e para onde a gente tem que
caminhar como a gente tem que tá em 2030
a responsabilidade é de todo mundo é dos
governos sim um governo supranacional
governo nacional que são os países
estados municípios é das empresas é da
sociedade civil organizada é do
indivíduo é do indivíduo
todo mundo tem que focar na agenda para
que a gente atinja esses objetivos
mas aqui eu quero focar em um dos atores
nas empresas
vou fazer uma comparação número 200 dos
200 maiores pibs do mundo
se compararmos pibs a receita quanto são
empresas
alguma tentativa aí quando empresas 200
comparando países a empresas quando as
empresas 70 escutei 70 em 180 cento e
oitenta e um pouco de exagero mais 154
gentili estar de um a 200 154 são
empresas
então a gente vê o potencial de impacto
que essas organizações têm impactos
positivos ou então negativos mas porque
eu quero dar atenção para esse público
porque eu entendo que por conta desse
potencial que eles têm e eu procuro
olhar o potencial é não só positivo
também o negativo mas estimular o
positivo
acho que isso que tem que ser feito né
sem dúvida nenhuma eu acredito que as
empresas são parte bastante importante
nessa mudança no atingimento dessas
metas
tá elas vêm se organizando a gente
acabou de assistir aqui no ambiente
online falando de algumas iniciativas
quando ela fala por exemplo contratação
de metas para ter só energia renovável
falando em empresas né quando se fala em
contratação de metas o quali zões que se
tem por aí r 100 por exemplo as empresas
que vão comprar só energia renovável
está a gente tem k vamos viver uma
palestra sobre resíduos
a gente tem então coalizões compromissos
das empresas globalmente falando de
resíduos
outro motivo do porque eu acredito nas
empresas como sendo o motor dessa
mudança a gente tem um outro dado bem
interessante que é o que a gente vê cada
dia mais países às vezes de esquerda às
vezes de direita às vezes mais
conservador
às vezes mais liberal e
muitas vezes se transformam de uma
democracia numa ditadura na ou seja
gente vê idas e vindas de governos
independente de onde eles estão o
espectro político
tá com as empresas o que a gente percebe
o setor privado que quando eles
contratam algumas metas
eles vão perseguir suas metas tá outra
diferença que eu vejo a questão do longo
prazo
então as empresas conseguem ali
estabelecer metas para 10 anos 20 anos o
que pra governos é muito difícil em se
tratando do nosso país
a gente vê a dificuldade que a gente tem
e muitas vezes as políticas são
renovadas a cada quatro anos
é por isso que eu acho que as empresas
têm uma parte bastante fundamental na
mudança dessa agenda na virada desse
jogo e no atingimento das metas né
quando assenge trata de países no
cenário global
a gente pensa no multilateralismo
constantemente escutamos que o
multilateralismo está em crise mas o que
falar do globalismo econômico a
globalização que foi estabelecida e
quando a gente pensa então na
interconectividade que existe a
interconexão que cada um de nós aqui
cada um cada uma de nós aqui temos com
qualquer pessoa em qualquer parte do
mundo
então isso ninguém tira
por isso entendo que de novo as empresas
têm um papel fundamental e o indivíduo
também tem um papel bastante fundamental
por isso gente eu queria trazer aqui que
o que para que a agenda de fato ela
funcione para que a gente atinja os
objetivos são 17 objetivos 169 metas e
as metas são as mais diversas
falei aqui desmatamento falei aqui
mortalidade infantil poderia ter falado
de trânsito poderia ter falado de
mudança do clima
de emprego seja lá o que for o espectro
é muito grande para a gente tratar de
todos os dilemas da humanidade
tá então a ideia que a gente viva no
mundo saudável com todos os recursos
naturais disponíveis para a humanidade
só que claro que a gente consiga cada
vez mais ao invés de desgatante
desgastá-lo recuperao isso é muito
importante mas o lema da agenda que eu
queria trazer aqui é o que é da gema
2000 da agenda 2030 é não deixar ninguém
para trás
meus caros nas caras pra não deixar
ninguém para trás
a gente vai precisar do trabalho não só
de governo não só de empresas não só da
sociedade civil organizada
mas a gente precisa do trabalho de cada
um de nós que está aqui dentro e ao
redor do mundo
obrigado
[Aplausos]